How did it go writing the code to save
the profile in the datastore? Let's take a quick look
at the code. Here I am, the saveProfile method.
And we'll scroll down to where we create the profile
and save it. So we already have this line
of code to create the profile and then saving it
in the entity was this simple, ofy.save.entity(profile).now. Okay, now
let's see what properties show up in the datastore admin.
So here we are in the Datastore Viewer looking
at the profile entity for my profile Lemon Cake.
See here, we have to display name and the
other properties that we see are the mainEmail and the
teeShirtSize. The property that's missing is User ID. The
User ID was specified as the ID for the entity
and it's used in the entity key. The ID
field isn't saved as a separated property on the entity.
Okay, let's go back and hear what Magnus has to say next.